how's it going guys today i want to show
you how to make some low poly
stones or rocks and blender with just a
really simple and really quick method
to do it somewhat randomly but still
have them look kind of nice so you'll
end up with something like this
all you do is you just launch blender
i'm using blender 2.9
and i'm going to start a new project and
take you from scratch so we're going to
delete this initial cube with the delete
button while it's selected
and then we're just going to add a new
mesh we can go up here and go add mesh
ico sphere i want to make sure we do an
ico sphere you can also do
shift a and go and get that menu
so once you have an ico sphere it looks
all right man look
not quite stone enough too circular for
a stone so what we want to do is go into
edit mode so you can either click up
here go to edit mode or just press tab
tab switches to it and you'll see it
by default has all the vertices selected
so you want to make
sure that they're selected if they're
not you can press a
for select all and what you want to do
next is just subdivide this a couple
times so
right click subdivide and go down here
to the menu
and it says number of cuts one let's
change this to
two we could do even more if you want if
you want finer detail
i like two it's not too high of detail
that it's not a million vertices so
there we go looks pretty good
uh we only got one vertices selected we
want to make sure we select them all for
this next step so i'm going to press
a to select them all now what we're
going to do is randomize these vertices
and you can just right click and go to
randomize vertices so there we go
do that once maybe do it twice right
click
random again you can also right click
and press r to do quick so there's three
times and the more you do this the more
crazy it's going to start looking
that might be a bit much so i'm going to
undo it a couple times
all right because i don't want these
vertices going
inside the object that's going to make
it look weird so what you want to do
next here is just smooth it
so that was one randomization and then
one smooth
and you might want to repeat this just a
few times so
randomize some oops
smooth randomize smooth
so after doing that a few times you
start to develop sort of a random
rock shape and that's really the whole
point here
and you can play around with this
smoothing a little bit
depending on how you want your rock to
look but i'm just going to randomize it
a few more times smooth it a few more
times
randomize again smooth again
and maybe one more smooth on this
there we go that's starting to look
pretty decent decent little random stone
there
and now we just want to add a rock
texture to this
and for doing that we're going to be
using a free image editor called [ __ ]
it's sort of like a photoshop
replacement and we're just going to make
a
simple rock-like texture so i'm going to
go to new
i'm going to make this 512 by 512 that's
a small enough texture
that it won't be giant you can make it
whatever size you want but i like 512
for starting out and testing
so what we're going to do here is just a
little bit of randomizing
to make a rock like texture so we're
going to
start by going up to filters and then
render noise solid noise
and this gives us sort of a cloud-like
pattern
and we're going to increase the detail a
little bit
because i feel like that looks more
rocky and maybe
depends how you want on this size what
kind of rock it is
we're going to stick with about four ish
4.7 sounds good
and we can also play around with these
two
tile turbulent i kind of like this
turbulent yeah i'm going to click this
turbulent
for this one so one of the points of
this is you can kind of play around with
it now we're going to add a new layer
we're going to leave this one as it is
go to layer
new layer or you can press ctrl shift
and
it's going to leave it all default there
should be the same size
and we're going to add some kind of
random stuff to this for this we're
going to go to
the bucket fill so you can do that with
shift b
or you can click up here and go to it
shift b
and we're just going to go to pattern
fill and pick one of these patterns i
like this slate so we're going to click
slate
and then we're just going to click in
here to fill the whole area now of
course it covers up this old background
which isn't exactly what we want
but that is okay we can just reduce the
opacity of this layer a little bit for
that behind one to show a little bit
and we see we already are getting a sort
of a rock
like texture which in my opinion doesn't
look
too bad so there's a lot of layering and
playing around you can do with here to
get it to look
even better but i'm already decently
happy with how this is so i'm just going
to merge these together
merge so there we have sort of a rocky
looking texture already
now this is a little bit bumpy so i
think maybe adding a little blur would
be nice so i'm going to go to filters
blur gaussian blur and increase the size
a little bit maybe to about
four point five or five
that's let's go with 3.5 that looks okay
i'm going to go ahead and tile seamless
there we go tile seamless didn't do much
but just in case just to make sure
so if we zoom out we can kind of get a
feel for it
and that's just a very simple rockish
texture there's so many different things
you can do to play around with to get
rock-like textures so
i don't want to go into too much much
detail or play around too much because
this will just take forever
so now we just want to export this let's
go to export
save it wherever you want make sure you
know how to find it i'm going to put it
in a created images folder call it brock
text
4 hit export
and then we're going to go back to
blender
so back in blender we just want to make
sure we have this all
we're on this ico sphere and then go to
materials
and it doesn't matter if you're an edit
or object i'm actually going to go back
an object though
and okay materials new
and it gives you a default one of a
principle bsdf
so we're just going to hit this base
color dot and then go to image
texture and then open
and then we're going to go to where we
saved that and i know it's called
rocktext4 there it is so i'm just going
to pick that
and it applies it you can't see it yet
you got to put this in rendered mode to
be able to see it
and you can do that by clicking these
little circles up here one of these is
rendered i'm not seeing it
but if you're not seeing you can just
press z and then go to render there
and there you go that is a rock with the
texture applied
we could use a few more lights so i'm
going to copy paste this light and move
it over
paste again move it over
and there we go and then when you're
ready you just export it
export obj
save it here i'm just going to call this
rock
and now that i know where to find it i
can use it in whatever i want
use it my game engine i can use it in
scenes of anything
you can drag it into unreal you can drag
it into unity
well that's it for this video hope you
enjoyed hope you're able to make a stone
yeah let me know what you think below
peace out guys